best-selling author michael lewis is
here to talk about his latest book on
america's handling of the pandemic
that's where the lost in the woods part
comes in he's one of the country's
best-known non-fiction writers the
author of 16 books over all three of
those books have been turned into
oscar-nominated movies his most recent
is the premonition a pandemic story it
explores why the u.s struggled to
respond to the coronavirus outbreak even
though it was thought to be
the best prepared country in the world
michael lewis good morning morning so we
had this great reputation everyone
thought we'd be ready if no one else was
and yet we didn't respond as anyone
expected yeah how come
no it's an incredible story actually
it's it's like it's like a highly ranked
college football team pre-season coming
in and just having and just muffing it
and i think i don't think the country
appreciates just how bad our response
was i mean right through the pandemic up
to the vaccine being distributed we had
fewer than five percent of the of the
people on the planet and more than 20 of
the deaths i mean we're looking at 750
000 dead americans right now so why was
it so bad um
in the first place um i mean we didn't
really have a system to respond to we
had we had this thing called the centers
for disease control which had evolved
into something that was more like an
academic institution and what has to
happen at the very beginning of the
pandemic is you have to be on like a
war-like footing where someone at the
center is actually directing and leading
a unified response and we never we never
really got the unified response right we
got this very divided take on what was
going on so that divided take is
actually what's most worrying now oh my
god we may be in a worse position than
we were because things have become
politicized and you can't just hose that
off that's not part of it so there is
this fictional that is out there that
you had a choice up front lives or
livelihood right you could let the thing
run and you'd have your economy
or you could shut things down and people
would suffer economically when you look
at around the world what's happened
that's a false choice um you know like i
mean it's like a natural experiment that
happened in the nordic countries sweden
let the thing run
denmark and norway similar countries
shut things down right sweden has five
times the death rate and more economic
damage so it's it was not either or it
was like you control this thing and you
get more of your economy but that's not
the message that's out here it's sort of
like you you pick a path and one and
you're you're actually getting something
on this other pet but you're not you're
getting right you know you're three
times more likely to die of covid in
miami than you are in san francisco wow
i mean that through the death rate is
three times a great why is that and what
i don't understand is why you know you
can see this now it's information
everybody can access that there is an um
a a general an agreed upon truth here
right that we can act on because instead
they're two camps so what happens the
next time this happens if it happens you
have instant polarization coming out of
the out of the chute because it makes
people kind of dug in their heels
and that's that's one of the problems
now i think we're maybe in a worse place
now speaking of two camps it seems like
america is somewhat divided on being
vaccinated not being vaccinated and
they're still fake
hear that right he's careful he has a
careful journal there is still a large
number of individuals that are not
vaccinating of course individuals like
kyrie irving mba's kyrie irving is
grabbing the headlines but we're talking
about men and women in the medical space
police officers and firefighters why do
you believe there are so many that still
won't get vaccinated this country has an
unbelievable ability to generate
knowledge and then not use it we created
the pandemic strategy that other
countries use to defend themselves and
now we've done it again with a vaccine
um
so
the short answer i mean there's not a
short answer right ev there are
different groups have different reasons
for being afraid of the vaccine and i'm
a little more sympathetic to kyrie
irving than i am to
some others but
the problem is that
rather than
us seeking for like agreed upon truths
all the stuff has gotten tribalized so
that like if you're in this group you're
a hostile vaccine and you're this group
you're supposed to get it um
what it is not is like evidence of
there's no evidence that the vaccine is
like
really dangerous i mean in fact just the
opposite right yeah you know hundreds of
millions of people been given this thing
and there's very little in the way of
right and on the other hand 750 000
americans you just showed a story right
about a guy who's living with long-haul
covet that's what's dangerous so the
fact that we
that we are incapable of like protecting
our people or even saving ourselves
it speaks to something that's deeper in
the culture
you know and and it was there before the
pandemic in the three years running up
the pandemic in for the first time in a
century this country suffered a a
decline in life expectancy and you kind
of say like what's going on here right
like we're basically failing
as a country to take care of our people
yeah and and this is just a continuation
yeah 738 000 covert related deaths in
this country since we last spoke to you
the number has gone up by more than 200
000 people struggle to comprehend that
it's a public tragedy still unfolding
since we last spoke to you you've also
suffered a personal tragedy that's true
if you and your wife tabitha lost a
child 19 year old dixie
we were terribly sorry to hear that
first of all how's your family doing how
are you doing and i am curious at a time
when so many families are losing that
this loss unrelated though it was
deepen your understanding of what the
country's going through so thank you uh
we loved her as much as parents can love
a child and she is
she was an incredible kid
it is a breathtaking blow
and
when you have to deal with an actual
loss
you feel it differently than you you
just hear about someone else's loss yeah
and it's it's it has it by turns
paralyzing and exhausting
and upsetting but it has actually it's
made me wonder like
i feel a numbness in the country like
the country has not really come to terms
with what has just happened it is it is
there's 750 000 families who've had this
similar hole blown
in there a lot blown in their lives and
you kind of wondered just what that does
to the energy of the country i i can
tell you it has been
rough on us and it has made me it's made
me appreciate that like
anything you can do
to to minimize the likelihood of other
this happening to other people you do
and it's why it's so upsetting that like
as a society we don't do it
um
so
yeah ooh it's it's as you're speaking
here i'm just remembering we're all
parents here uh and so many families
have lost children um
so many children have lost parents and
i'm reminded of your your book on
fatherhood that's really taken my breath
away she's you know she's a big part of
it right yeah
and with these numbers start to become
just numbers you think huh you can go
seven you know what number does it take
for us to wake up um
when it's a person when it's when it's a
specific person
and you then multiply that in your head
so the characters in this book did all
the characters in my book are doctors uh
and they are people who try to set us up
to succeed in this pandemic and you want
them to be celebrated and i want them to
be celebrated
we have to leave it there we want that
success to happen people need to read
the book yeah thank you very much thanks
for having me the book is the
premonition it is on sale now